[музика]
українські військові змушені економити
боєприпаси поки не надійшли поставки
зброї від партнерів України командир
українського танкового взводу в
Донецькій області рахує кожен снаряд для
танка т-64 І от Вони мають думати про те
щоб чи знищити Цей міномет зараз там
трьома чотирма пострілами а потім буде
не вистачати десь в іншому місці де буде
більш серйозніша ситуація чи краще
потримати пережити цей міномет там
знищити його там з Асса з якогось
кулеметів намагатися снайперською
боротьбою тобто і ну тобто
намагаємося економити боєприпаси для
того щоб у випадку якщо буде прорив ми
могли потім протиставити якусь силу Ми
не можемо знищувати кожну ціль яку
виявляє
за словами командира Перемоги України
залежатиме від того наскільки швидко
українські військові отримують зброю від
партнерів
якщо ми не
то ми будемо далі отримувати
позицію Скажімо так і ця війна може дуже
сильно затягнутися все залежить від
швидкості поставки озброєння Зараз тут і
зараз через те що в нас єсть з цього
моменту є ще півроку для того щоб ми
могли активно вести Контрнаступ в
адекватних умовах із мінімум уже до
осінніх дощів після осінніх дощів нам
так само буде важко наступати як її
у ЄС домовилися надати Україні
артилерійських боєприпасів на два
мільярди євро перша партія складе 1 млн
снарядів які мають надійти впродовж року
[музика]
це стратегічні крок те що додає
впевненості в нашій єдності в
незмінності руху до перемоги над
державою терористом Дякую усім нашим
партнерам в Європі усім хто дійсно
зацікавлений щоб Європа була сильною
вільною оголошення сьогодні і про новий
оборонний пакет від Сполучених Штатів
Америки обсяг 350 мільйонів доларів це
ракети для хаймарсів артилерійські та
інші боєприпаси все що дійсно необхідно
щоб підтримати наших воїнів
за оцінками військового експерта Романа
світана обіцяного ЄС мільйона снарядів
має вистачити на три місяці наступальних
дій ЗСУ
в сутки украинской армии за добу
українська армія використовує 5 тисяч
снарядів це в оборонному режимі
для наступального потрібно близько 10
тисяч тобто приблизно потрібно близько
300 тисяч нарядів на місяць а це означає
що мільйон снарядів буде витрачено при
наступі за три місяці тобто мільйон
снарядів це тримісячний запас нарядів
для виконання наступальних дій А це
виконання одного наступу або одного
етапу наступу із визволенням Криму
у Брюсселі Міністра закордонних справ ЄС
домовилися надати Києву мільйон снарядів
калібру 155 мм вони використовуються у
західних видах артилерії які союзники
передають Україні проте деяким країнам
доведеться буквально спустошити склади
адже Європа не готувалася до війни
останні 20 років після закінчення
холодної війни ми європейці скорочували
нашу військову міць
факт у тому що ми скоротили наші
військові витрати вдвічі
і згідно з нашими даними витрати на
виробництво боєприпасів були скорочені
вчетверо А тепер раптово нам треба
збільшувати їх через обстановку що
радикально змінилася
за словами німецького міністра оборони
боєприпаси буде закуплено як У рамках
національних програм так і в рамках
єдиного європейського замовлення
наша першочергова мета і вона має
абсолютне пріоритет відправити значну
кількість боєприпасів в Україну до кінця
року
артилерія відіграє ключову роль у
протистоянні в якому Ані Росія Ані
Україна не можуть на повну силу
використати авіацію
90%. Справа в тому що 90% поразків
такого роду в війнах коли не
використовується авіації А у нас немає
авіації для того щоб використовувати її
а росіяни не можуть свою авіацію
використовувати Бо у нас дуже сильна
нині система ППО ми просто не даємо їм
її використовувати і не використання
авіації вивело на перше місце
використання артилерії і повернуло так
званим богам війни і їхні п'єдестал
тема дефіциту снарядів Українській армії
настільки важливо що про неї навіть
говорив канцлер Німеччини шольц
виступаючи нещодавно перед депутатами
бундестагу європейцями ще кілька років
тому здавалося що масштабна війна в
Європі така мала ймовірна що снаряди
більше не потрібні тепер у ЄС
обговорюють схему централізованої
закупівлі снарядів Аналогічно до
закупівель вакцини від коронавірусу тим
часом за даними стокгольмського
міжнародного інституту дослідження
проблем Миру третина всіх поставок зброї
в Україну зі США 17% з Польщі та 11
німецьких озброєння
до 2022 року Україна була незначним
одержувачем зброї незважаючи на Ситуацію
в якій вона знаходилася але зараз ми
бачимо що вона збільшила імпорт зброї чи
краще сказати отримала багато зброї від
цілої низки європейських держав та США і
ми бачимо що за останній рік стало
значним отримувачем зброї
місяць тому Федеральна Рада Безпеки
Німеччини схвалила постачання Україні
178 модернізованих танків леопард 1 з
промислових запасів а до річниці початку
війни Берліна носував ще постачання
чотирьох танків леопард-2 А6 28 лютого
німецький концерн райметаль повідомив що
системи ППО скайнекс та Sky Ranger теж
були відправлені в Україну Також Варшава
активно постачає Україні танки 27 січня
прем'єр-міністр Польщі заявив що крім 14
танків Леопард 2 Польща поставить
Україні ще 30 танків т-72м та 60 танків
піті 91 а Міноборони США у річницю
початку війни оголосила про новий пакет
військової допомоги Україні обсягом 2
млрд доларів ідеться пробує припаси для
реактивних систем залпового вогнюхай
Марс та ракетних систем з лазерним
наведенням кілька типів Дронів обла
днання для виявлення засобів
радіоелектронної боротьби артилерійські
боєприпаси а також обладнання для
розмінування місцевості